bien en el vídeo pasado me quedé
terminando este problema número 18 y
bueno esencialmente llegamos a esta
ecuación de aquí que es una ecuación
cuadrática y lo único que hay que hacer
es resolver esta parte de aquí para
obtener el valor de x así que pues vamos
a hacerlo y este es el final de este
problema número 18 y que me queda cuánto
es 17 al cuadrado
espero tener un poco de espacio para
poder hacerlo lo voy a hacer aquí 17 por
17 a 7 749 llevamos 47 x 17 y 4 son 11 y
después aquí me quedaría 10 y 17 17 ok y
cuando yo os muestro me quedan 98 y aquí
217 al cuadrado es 289 289 es igual y
aquí aquí tengo un vino en el cuadrado
perfecto por lo tanto vamos a
desarrollarlo
cuadrado el primero es decir x cuadrada
más dos veces el primero por el segundo
por el segundo es negativo por lo tanto
me va a quedar menos 20 x 2 x x menos 10
me da menos 20 x más cuadrado del
segundo más 100 ya esto le voy a sumar 3
menos 18 esto es menos quince menos
quince elevado al cuadrado menos quince
elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 15 elevado al cuadrado y
15 elevado al cuadrado sin mis tablas no
me fallan es 225 225 este es uno de los
típicos números que se elevan cada rato
al cuadrado y bueno tengo una ecuación
cuadrática por lo tanto para resolver
una ecuación cuadrática que te parece si
igualamos todo a cero así que voy a
igualar esta parte a cero y me va a
quedar que 0 es igual a equis cuadrada
menos 20
más 100 más 225 225 menos y este va a
pasar del otro lado con signo contrario
menos 289 y cuantos todo esto de aquí
esto se puede simplificar a 100 más 225
estos dos son 325 325 ya esto le voy a
quitar 289 y que me queda 9 para 15 son
6 y llevo una después me queda 99 para
dos estrés y llevo una este baja y
entonces 3 menos 30 entonces todo esto
se reduce a 36
todo esto es 36 y entonces al final me
queda la ecuación cuadrática 0 es igual
a equis cuadrada menos 20
x 36 y bueno esta ecuación cuadrática la
podemos resolver de varias formas
inclusive podemos utilizar la fórmula
cuadrática sin embargo creo que es mucho
más fácil factorizar lo en lugar de
hacer toda esta ecuación
voy a actualizar esta parte de aquí y
dice dos números que multiplicados me
den 36 y sumados me den menos 20 am-
tienen que ser dos números negativos a
ver qué números multiplicados me dan 36
6 x 6 6 x 6 36 pero la suma mental 12
12 33 por 12 es lo mismo que 36 pero la
suma me da 15
18 18 y 2 claro 18 por 23 36 y por otra
parte 18 y 2 me dan 20 por lo tanto esta
expresión de aquí y déjame ponerlo por
acá ya que se acabó este problema es
exactamente lo mismo que decir x menos
18 que multiplica a x2 esto igualado a
cero y de aquí ya puedo obtener el valor
de x porque porque cuando tengo una
ecuación de esta forma estoy diciendo
que x menos 18 esto es igual a cero o en
su dado caso x 2 es igual a 0 de la
primera obtengo que x es igual a 18 o en
su dado caso de la segunda obtengo que x
es igual a 2 y estos son mis dos
posibles valores para x o x igual a 18 x
igualados
son mis soluciones de este problema si
el punto a es el punto 18,3 en su dado
caso es el punto 23 entonces la
distancia
el punto b 10 18 es 17 unidades y bueno
ya está este fue un vídeo bastante corto
donde lo único que hice fue acabar el
último problema de esta sección número 4
del examen número 3 del s ate así que es
todo por esta sección es todo por este
vídeo y nos vemos en la siguiente
sección y en el siguiente vídeo hasta la
próxima